okay it's not for any jobs but it was
for something that was very meaningful
of me it was in college community
college actually it was in because it
was back to the Peter Pan thing through
Peter Pan it was my last time and
community cut my last production in
Community College and there's a festival
nationwide thing I remember how it's
like Nash North American theatre
conference or something like that it was
it's a big to-do where it all culminates
at the Kennedy Center in DC they go to
different colleges people are nominated
from each school and their departments
to go and represent their school doing a
scene for this big theatre festival and
it's like a contest sort of like a mini
version of the Oscars or something where
you pick who wins and all that stuff and
I wanted to be involved in that for
years finally because I got like this
little bit part instead of the thing in
Peter Pan but it was like I did whatever
I could with it and then they ended up
nominating me to go and represent the
school so I got a scene partner and
we're practicing and we had the
qualifying audition I guess even though
we were chosen but you have to make sure
you go through the big round to actually
go to the thing and I screwed the line
up so bad the line was it was from Wendy
coming around Red Rider or something
like that and between a man and a woman
and I say to the girl you have you have
you have really pretty lips or you have
a really beautiful lips because he's
about the kisser
and during one of our practices I did
the the delivers things like you got a
real party mouth and never never make a
joke in a rehearsal because that'll
stick in the performance I'll be damned
if that didn't happen in the room on the
day in front of like 50 people oh my god
just eruptions of laughter it was
humiliating awful awful and I was like
it suffice to say I didn't get in so
yeah that was my that was pretty awful
you